was wisst welche brauche ich doch gar
okay es zurück denn es geht hier ist
euer max und wir spielen heute community
clash gegen den lieben gott was geht
hallo ich bin hier in meiner ersten
runde gerade f5 videos gesagt hast und
die werden wir werden gerade erst alle
vereinzelt teleportiert okay ich bin
gespannt die karte leo vier spiele mit
120 spielern es ist nicht ganz voll aber
freunde
es sieht kraft aus ist minimal anlegen
wo hier alle leute langsam gehts auch
wirklich sehr genau recherchiert
überflüssig und wir gehen so richtigen
gegenmittel
ich bin gespannt und dann wie gesagt du
kannst ohne rücksicht auf verluste
kannst du drauf gehen weil du hast nicht
begrenzte leben die spieler haben jetzt
am anfang alle nur ein leben und dann
zeig mal was du drauf hast
naja schauen wir mal ich gehe nur auf
dich drauf ich kenne die karte noch gar
nicht so richtig aber der weg ist ja
eigentlich doch schon jetzt doch das
merkt man ihr pannen in den ewigen mit
ok darum stehst du so auf das war nicht
gut okay ist leicht um längen
wahrscheinlich liegen wobei es geht dank
geht da bist du ja da habe ich hier ein
standhafter schädel alter okay dann bist
du okay der server ist am struggle ich
glaube die große gestorben echt ja weil
ich das nicht schade weil die große
karte mit vielen spielern macht gleich
ein bisschen zu schaffen ich hoffe mal
dass das sich noch ein bisschen
stabilisiert wenn die ersten rausfliegen
aber dein team führt gerade sie
scoreboard rechts
was bedeutet 25 das sind das sind die
themen us-team leben ok ja ich glaube
ich mache erst ein bisschen distanz und
bogen wird sich zu 45 ich will gerade wo
du stehst
hamburg erstmals wasser ich lege mir
drei kills liegt mein team vorne
ich wünsche mir richtig schaden hier oh
mann ich muss einmal komplett außen
umgehen hast du schon kehl ich habe noch
gar kein ich will hier vor den roten
ich habe noch ich habe auch noch kein
kind 1 638 erwarten da vorne ist ein
nach seinem team auf das schiff
das hat ihn aber ist nicht der mit so
100 leuten auf sami die karte zu spielen
das wäre ich auch richtig krasser kommen
auch mal ausprobieren und jutta und
ähnlich wie er ist es schon zu klein
keine danach normale chaos und spielen
fünf dein team age zerstören
ok [ __ ] [ __ ] berührt gerade ist und kein
herz ein herz was ich würde irgendwie
durch eine getötete paket jetzt erstmal
wieder ab in die mitte zurück vermutlich
den ersten kill bleiben stehen dann auch
ihre teamkameraden holt sich den
abstauber das weiter schlechte man hin
und her so ganz knapp verpasst ich mein
kind an sich ist es ja gut für dich
selbst ist kurve lukas bishop punkte
aber es muss ja als als community gut
verfahren das stimmt im bestfall da seid
ihr momentan wenig besseres leben
betrifft ein ganz bisschen wort ja immer
auch ein knappes ding wo wir dürfen
nicht zu sehr angreifen
ich find die karte ist ein grieche cool
fertig gebaut ist sie wunderschön
wirklich also gefällt mir richtig ich
bewege mich auch wieder in die mitte
mussten ich bin gerade gestorben also
ich habe ein kind zwei tode tolle kaffee
ich habe einen toten kills kann meine
karte ist bei null
deine beine kommen fünf richtig also
wissen du bist es war verdammt ich
wollte gerade sagen weiter aber nein
jetzt elf team leben mehr
oli das ist natürlich ziemlich gut da
wirst du was ausgleich müssen aber ich
meine du kannst ja zu ganz guten
höchstform auflaufen was pvp angeht was
ich von so manchem projekt gesehen hallo
und wenn es drauf ankommt dann werde ich
auch gerne zum tier
ja ich weiß nicht ob du den du deine
community verteidigen kannst da hätte
ich weiter gefordert der gelobte fall
sogar von dir nicht sicher bist du dann
direkt vor dir da warst du der held die
herzlichste wäre hätte ich sogar getötet
das gibt sich den ersten kill bringe ich
dir das stimmt nicht auf ihre us to
direct fünf punkte bekommen war er gut
als dass ein kaliber du der könig ist
und die lexa moment die ausbeute ist
kann man richtig pipi machen also
wirklich du solltest ohne rücksicht auf
verluste drauf wenn du könntest auch
wenn ich hier mal ein paar tipps geben
sagt wo ich dem team dass sie sich zum
sport zurückziehen sollen weiter kannst
du halt immer wieder sparen und so viele
von meinen leuten wegschmelzen wie es
geht und verstecken sich hier in seinen
reihen leute jetzt los habe eine granate
geworfen irgendwie hat die glaub ich
diesmal nicht ganz so viel gebracht
okay die erste die macht hat keine fünf
herzen schaden so weil du kannst was
weiß ich komme ganz viele leute
angreifen wenn ihr auf einem punkt
stehen
ok hanni boogie nights noch einige
machtkämpfe grad mitten im wasser leben
der brücke war okay hast gerade werdet
ihr ein bisschen geschnetzelt ja ihr
habt irgendwie auch das doppelte gefühl
hast du noch ein pakets gemacht leider
nicht bis jetzt aber das kommt noch eine
frau jetzt erkennbar ist wie das geht
ich möchte die punkte für die kinder des
königs war aber du hast am anfang des
biotech schneller kannst du hier gut weg
von den leuten hier kämpfen
auch deswegen überlege ich so lange
immer aber ihr verliert auch eng wie
kaum ein leben das ist der vorteil davon
sind 2
ok ich gebe ihm verboten ist auch sehr
schön einnahmen uns noch cool von deinem
team ja der geht der trend geht immer
automat ich habe jetzt sechs kills ok oh
jetzt kann's halt aufholen weil die
karte so groß ist sind müssen wir deine
ganzen einzelne leute irgendwie finden
und auch bei und ausfindig machen
okay der typ hier vorne hatten
ausplaudern dass das vielleicht eine
bank und man weiß ich hab mir körper
fertig gekauft wie kann ich dir einfach
schießen einfach schießen
also ja ich habe das eigentlich
siebenkämpferin komplett stehen nach
oben platz stehen also wissen nein
niemals
ich mach gut kills gerade weil der typ
mit dem spawn von dir wirklich gut was
muss ich sagen er nahm an
ich möchte gerne dich mal kommt ein
halbes herz gerade also ob das war aber
nicht verstecken erlebe das mit meinen
krebs und er kommt auch nicht
natürlich hoffe ich auf dich wo alter
200 hertz und zwei herzen zu herzen
das gibt sich das gibt's nicht der lauf
wie die fünf punkte mehr davon will ich
geheult fast und kommt bis meine freude
das wäre auch zu schön gewesen okay du
bist du schon wieder auf mich natürlich
als teenager habe ich nicht ich werde
ich auch noch meine kids upgrade und
weil ich das ja perfekt und ballt noch
mehr punkte für wieviel hast du jetzt
insgesamt ich habe 16 punkte
ich hab' ich habe 18 er ist mein kind
auch erstmalige upgraded weiß ich mach
halt die effizienten gleich viermal
getötet ok es bislang
garantien oder vergiss es vergessen dass
jemand an meiner form einer army hat
zombies wird und was du mich mein glück
anders bekommen die anderen auch fünf
punkte für japan verkehr jetzt kannst du
wieder in einem spot schutz angelaufen
und deine leute verkämpfen sich die
richtige richtig frech die community
community klar ist dass die leute
zusammen gerufen das sind deine er ja
gut aber sie sind ja in dein team
geringer eine kämpferin ja wäre der
abwehr gesagt die profis bitte zu mir
ins team
aber es leben auch noch zwei andere
jetzt ist endlich noch einer von ihr
gestorben und da ist noch einer perfekt
okay das gleich daneben der freund
weiter auf unser team und mich weg mit
einer s bahn station ein herzen
nein jetzt kommen dass das würde ich
nicht verkraften wenn ich dich jetzt
nicht über gott oh gott ein herz ein
herz an herz an herz kommt heute das
gibt es nicht wo ich doch da ich hab ich
echt cool die artikel bist du jetzt echt
wohl noch der andere steckt einer ist
noch unterwegs
aber wo ein einziger das da vorne ist
schon wieder duo auf jeden fall herzen
ganz regenerierten derzeit vielleicht
gut dass du es immer noch an sagt und
kann ich mich immer noch ein bisschen
mehr freuen und ein arzt endlich schnell
hier die so perfekt jetzt habe ich auch
dein letzten den letzten spieler habe
ich jetzt auf dem trecker perfekt also
hier übrigens noch skype auf online ich
hoffe mal dass das kein jetzt habe ich
einfach 18 kills ich habe fünf kills
aber mir fehlen nur noch fünf punkte
vielleicht dich einmal schnitt sind und
dann kann ich mir mein zweites geht
abrede
leider wird dabei das casual ich bin auf
31 punkten jetzt dadurch dass so viele
leute von mir noch gelebt haben ich bin
auf drei punkte also ich weine bekommen
hast du ja gut für dein team poker ich
habe ganz gute sachen dafür bekommen
erklärt dann will ich gespannt dann wird
ja das sieht echt spannend als diese auf
der hase gekämpft
so leicht nebelig ist alles bei mir hier
musste ich gehen aber direkt drauf oder
natürlich natürlich dass auf jeden fall
müssen irgendwas gutes zusammensuchen
mit dem ich wirklich schaden machen kann
was denkst du kriegst nichts geschenkt
ich habe bis eine ganz gute kombination
dann kann ich glaube ich arbeiten
so wollen wir es jetzt schon sagen was
wir haben er oder nein denn ist
eigentlich schwer
also ich renne auf mich zu dann bereit
meiner community alle ehre
okay das bin ich auch
die killstreaks oder sehr wenige der du
hast ja gut gemacht das ist nicht die
sache 278 blöcke wenn du richtig machst
dich so wie viel wie weit entfernt ist
ach ja stimmt ist dann weiß ja wo ich
bin ich wollte mich eigentlich
anschleichen erst war das entsprechende
items nur anschleichen
aber die kann ich mir nicht leisten
wovon ungerecht hierbei die auf der
hälfte ist alles voller sonne voll
gemütlich bei mir alles so schatten und
nebel als ich was gelaufen bin
ok jetzt bestimmt ein special
was will brauche ich doch gar nicht okay
mir als zurück
denn
vom hengst hallo kran kraft ist gestoppt
ich habe mich gerade mit dem enterhaken
selbst getötet das gewonnen
ich bin eine dummheit gestorben ach
quatsch da ist es schon soweit ich es
jetzt nämlich neuen halb herzen und alle
lachen hier aus dem chat
die reaktion ist auch richtig cool dass
man jetzt noch von der community zurück
ok misst wir haben auch für kommen noch
eine folge aufgenommen also schaut er
auf seinem kanal vorbei die ist ganz
oben in der schreibung verlinkt und dann
macht's gut